[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع
جوانبه نبدا بابراز العناوين
هي
مجموعه مسلحه
تم بيل
جروده داخل الحدود الروسيه
اعمده الدخان تتصاعد بالخرطوم على مواقع
اشتباكات واو واشنطن تعمل على اليه
لمراقبه الهدنه بالسودان
قبيل ايام من جوله الاعاده برئاسيات تركيا
خلافات تطرا على حزب اردوغان والسبب الخطط
الاقتصاديه
وتتابعون معنا الليله ايضا
ورئيس مجلس النواب يتهم الديمقراطيين
بزياده الانفاق لاعلى مستوى بتاريخ البلاد
قلى قائد ما يطلق عليه فيلق المتطوعين
الروس دنيس كابو ان مجموعته ستقوم بعمليات
توغل في الدخل الروسي قريبا واضاف
كابوستين ان المرحله الاولى من الهجوم عبر
استهداف مقاطعه كانت ناجحه وان العمليه
مستمره
الجديده هي مهاجمه مناطق جديده في روسيا
والتواغل فيها ليس عليكم سوى الانتظار
قليلا لايام عده فقط كي تشاهدون في الجزء
الاخر من الحدود
[موسيقى]
الى ذلك اعلن حاكم منطقه بيروغرود الروسيه
ان السلطات المقاطعه شكلت سبعه كتائب دفاع
تضم نحو ثلاثه الاف شخص لتامين الحدود مع
اوكرانيا واوضح حاكم بيلوجرود ان السلطات
تدرس تسليحه تلك المجموعات مشيرا الى انها
تتدرب منذ نوفمبر الماضي واكد المسؤول
الروسي ان الحاجه لتلك الكتائب ظهرت بعد
الهجوم الاخير على بيلوج
توعد وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجيش ويجو برد
صارم على اي محاولات لتوغل مسلحين للحدود
الروسيه
[موسيقى]
الى ذلك اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
التصدي لهجوم بحري شنته ثلاث زوارق
اوكرانيه سريعه مسيره على سفينه ايفان
فورس التابعه لاسطول البحر الاسود في
منطقه مضيق البوسفوره وقال المتحدث باسم
الوزاره ايغور كوناشينكوف انه تم تدمير
جميع القوارب المعاديه في زمن قياسي مشيرا
الى ان السفينه الروسيه كانت تقوم بحمايه
خطي غاز ترك ستريم وبلوس ستريم في المنطقه
الاقتصاديه التركيه واكد ان السفينه ايفان
فورس التابعه لاسطول البحر الاسود تواصل
اداء مهامها
اليوم في تمام الساعه الخامسه والنصف
صباحا قامت القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
بمحاوله فاشله لمهاجمه سفينه ايفانخورس
التابعه لاسطول البحر الاسود بثلاثه زوارق
مسيره دمرت جميع قوارب العدو نيران التسلح
القياسي لسفينه روسيه على بعد 140
كيلومترا شمال شرقي مضيق البوسفور
ان اعلنت روسيا السيطره على بخمه المدينه
التي دار فيها القتال لاشهر مع القوات
الاوكرانيه انتهاك معارك باخموت انتهائها
ربما سيعني انتقال المعارك لمناطق اكبر
مثل كراماتورسك
في مقاطعه الا ان خبراء يرون ان تسلم
الجيش الروسي لزمام الامور في باخموت
سيدفع موسكو للتحول من مرحله الهجوم كما
كان الوضع في المدينه الى وضعيه الدفاع
استعدادا للهجوم الاوكراني المضاد موسكو
طبعا تعمل ايضا على تمكين خطوط دفاعها وفي
ذات الوقت محاوله ضرب التحركات
الاوكرانيه بالصواريخ والمدفعيه وايضا
سلاح الجو خاصه وان وزاره الدفاع قالت
انها على علم بتفاصيل الخطه الاوكرانيه
المضاده في الاثناء ستعمل روسيا على ضمان
الاحتفاظ بالاراضي التي سيطرت عليها نذكر
هنا اعلان يفغيني ان قوته ستحتاج لشهرين
للراحه لاعداد وتدريب المقاتلين الجدد رغم
اتخاذ مواضع دفاعيه حول باخمت روسيا هجوما
جويا على مدينه نيبرو بجنوب شرق اوكرانيا
فيما افادت وسائل الاعلام بوقوع السلسله
من الانفجارات وافادت وسائل الاعلام محليه
بسماع خمسه عشره انفجارا في المدينه خلال
ساعه ونصف من القصف الروسيه المتواصل وعلى
الجانب الاخر اعلنت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه انها تعمل على بناء خطوط
دفاعيه قويه امام تقدم محتمل للقوات
الروسيه الى مدينتي كرامات
يستبعد خبراء عسكريون قيام اي جانب
بتحركات في القريب العاجل نحو مدن جديده
على ان يقتصر الامر على كر وفر بين
الجانبين في اشتباكات سريعه ايضا الدخول
في معارك استنزاف كما ربما يدفع موسكو
للتفكير مع تحشيدك للاليات والصواريخ التي
حصلت عليها من الغرب ولكن من المتوقع ان
تكون المرحله القادمه ساخنه جدا وفق خبراء
مع غموض توجهات الجيشين ان كان الروسي او
الاوكراني في القادم من الايام طبعا مع
الاستعدادات الاوكرانيه للهجوم المضاد
الذي طال انتظاره وانضم الينا من موسكو
عبر سكايب السيد بافل
فيلينج هاور المحلل العسكري اهلا بك سيد
بابل يعني كيف تصف هذا التطور النوعي
بالمواجهه مسيرات مائيه
بالبوسفور هي بعيده عن ساحه المواجهه بين
اوكرانيا وروسيا هل توافق على ما تقوله
موسكو بان الغرب يحاول تكرار ما فعله في
بحر البلطيق من استهداف لخط انابيب نور
ستريم
اعتقد ان
الانابيب الغاز في البحر الاسود
هي تعمل منذ فتره من الزمن وهي في الواقع
لا تصل الى
المضيق البوسفور هي تصل الى تركيا وترى
روسيا ان هناك تهديد محتمل ان يتعرض خط او
انبوب الغاز الى الهجوم وانا لست متاكد من
ان اوكرانيا مستعده للقيام
بتحرك من هذا القبيل لان ذلك سيكون له
تاثير سلبي على تركيا
هناك طبعا استخدام من قبل الاوكرانيين
للطائرات المسيره البحريه والان يستخدم
هذه الزوارق السريعه
المسيره
وقد تم
تم استخدام هذا النوع من
الاسلحه من قبل الاوكرانيين في السابق مثل
المسيرات التي تم اعتراضها وهذا جزء لا
يتجزا من المعارك المستمره
وفصل الصيف على الابواب
والجنوب اوكرانيا ومنطقه البحر الاسود
هناك زياده في الانشطه العسكريه لان هذه
الموسم هو موسم القتال الاساسي ويامل
الاوكرانيون ان يحققوا النجاح ويغير مجرى
الحرب خلال
هذه الفتره من القتال في فصل الصيف الذي
حل في الوقت الراحم وبالتالي سيد بافضل هل
تعتبر ان الهجوم المضاد الذي لا طالما
تحدثت اوكرانيا انها تعتزم القيام به قد
بدا
[موسيقى]
لم يبدا بعد
وسنعلم
المزيد عن ذلك وربما قد يحدث الهجوم
المضاد من خلال اوكرانيا لهجوم واسع
النطاق
بالصواريخ طويله ضد مراكز القياده والتحكم
الروسيه وكذلك شبكات
الاتصالات من اجل حرمانها القوات الروسيه
من
الحصول على الاوامر من
القياده العليا للجيش الروسي ولكن
بالتاكيد سيكون هناك طبعا هجمات واسعه
النطاق من قبل الاوكرانيين الذين سوف
يسعون للتركيز على نقاط القوه لديهم وموسم
القتال الصيفي سوف يستمر حتى شهر اكتوبر
اذا الفتره الزمنيه طويله ويدرك
الاوكرانيون ان هذا يمثل فرصه كبيره لهم
واذا ما حققوا النجاح فان اوكرانيا يمكن
ان تحقق الكثير والا فان اوكرانيا سوف
تضطر للقبول ربما بنجاحات اقل بكثير
حتى يتم ربما توصل الى اتفاق مع روسيا
بشان وقف لاطلاق النار على اساس خطوط
التماس الراهنه
الفيلق حريه روسيا تبنى الهجوم على
بيلوغرود هجوم الامس خطوره ان يكون لروسيا
اعداء روس من الداخل ولماذا الان
ظهر او يعني اصبح لديه عمليات يقوم بهذا
الفيلق
ليس لدي اي اهميه استراتيجيه فهذا ما حدث
مثلا اثناء دعم صدام حسين
المشقين الايرانيين مثل مجاهدي خلق وهذا
الامر موجود في الكثير من البلدان والان
الاوكرانيون يقومون بهذا الامر ذاته شكرا
السيد
المحلل العسكري حدثنا من موسكو
اكدت الخارجيه الفرنسيه استعدادها تزويد
اوكرانيا بمعدات عسكريه موضحه ان دعمها لا
يعني انها في حرب مع روسيا
قمنا بتزويد معده نوعيه
كمدفعيه والدفاع الجوي
ونقوم بجهد ضخم فيما يتعلق
بالتدريب ايضا ومن اخر الاخبار
لاستعداد الفرنسي لتدريب طيارين الجيش
السلاح الجويه الاوكراني
وقمنا ايضا بتزويد مدفع مصفحه خفيفه
وقرر الرئيس ان ليس هناك اي محظور
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد منورات عسكريه مشتركه
بين الولايات المتحده والنرويج تزيد مستوى
التوتر مع الجار الروسي وصوله حامل
الطائرات امريكيه الى ميناء اوسلو دفع
السفاره الروسيه في النرويج للتعليق بان
هذه المناورات غير منطقيه وضاره
اكبر حامله طائرات امريكيه في العالم
وصلت الى النرويج هدفها المشاركه في
مناورات مشتركه في اول انتشار قتالي لها
لضخامتها وخطورتها امر الجيش النرويجي
اصحاب المراكب الصغيره بالابتعاد عنها
تعمل الحامله بالطاقه النوويه
وتنشئ امريكا حاملاتين من نفس الطراز
طاقمها يبلغ
200600 فرد
وجودها في اوسلو ازعج الروس علقت السفاره
الروسيه في النرويج مظاهر القوه هذه تبدو
غير منطقيه وضاره تشترك النرويج وروسيا
بحدود بطول 198 كيلو مترا في القطب
الشمالي
اكد الرئيس الصيني على دعم بيكي لمصالح
موسكو الاساسيه وخلال اجتماع عقده مع رئيس
الوزراء الروسي ميخائيل ميشوستين اشار الى
مواصله البلدين تقديم الدعم الثابت
لبعضهما البعض فيما يتعلق
بمصالحهما الاساسيه وفي المحافل الدوليه
[موسيقى]
اطلق الجيش السوداني قذائف من منطقه
المهندسين تجاه تمركز قوات الدعم السريع
هذا وتتواصل الاشتباكات بين طرفين الصراع
وتزيد حدتها في ام درمان وافادت انباء
سودانيه بان قوات الدعم السريع تتاهبوا
لشن هجوم على مواقع الجيش في محيط منطقه
المهندسين
في السياق اكد البيت الابيض في تصريحات
لقناه العربيه تماسك الهدنه في السودان
لكن اشار الى انه من الوقت المبكر الحكم
عليها الهدنه من او الهدف من هذه الهدنه
حسب البيت الابيض هو السماح بوصول
المساعدات الانسانيه بالوصول للمدنيين كما
اضاف ان الولايات المتحده
ستنظر في خطوات اخرى في المرحله القادمه
على انها تعمل مع شركائها في اليه لمراقبه
الهدنه في السودان
المفاوض السامي للامم المتحده لحقوق
الانسان فلك قال ان اتفاقات وقف اطلاق
النار لا يتم احترامها كما اشار الى تعرض
المدنيين للخطر
ما يحدث في السودان لا امر مفجع على الرغم
من اتفاقات وقف اطلاق النار المتتاليه
فاننا نرى انه يتم خرقها في غضون ساعات
نرى كيف يستمر تعرض المدنيين لخطر الموت
والاصابه يعني بين عشيه وضحاها تلقينا
تقارير عن طائرات مقاتله عبر الخرطوم
واشتباكات في بعض مناطق المدينه وكذلك
سماع اطلاق النار في شمال الخرطوم وفي ام
درمان
[موسيقى]
كانت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه انه في ضوء
ما تم بحثه بين ولي العهد السعودي الامير
محمد بن سلمان ورئيس الوزراء الكندي
جاستون على هامش قمه منتدى التعاون
الاقتصادي لاسيا والمحيط الهادئ في بانكوك
في نوفمبر الماضي فقد تقرر اعاده مستوى
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه مع كندا الى وضعها
السابق واوضحت الخارجيه السعوديه في بيان
ان استئناف العلاقات مع كندا على اساس
الاحترام المتبادل والمصالح المشتركه هذا
واعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الكنديه تعيين جون
فيليب سفيرا جديدا لدى السعوديه
قبل ايام من من انتخابات الاعاده الرئاسيه
في تركيا حدث خلاف داخل حزب رجب طيب
اردوغان بشان التمسك بما يسميه البعض
برنامجا اقتصاديا غير مستدام بحسب وكاله
رويترز حيث اجتمعت مجموعه غير رسميه من
اعضاء الحزب الحاكم في الاسابيع الاخيره
لمناقشه كيف يمكن ان تتبنى سياسه جديده
لرفع اسعار الفائده تدريجيا وافادت مصادر
مطلعه لوكاله رويترز ان اردوغان ليس
مشاركا بشكل مباشر في هذه المحادثات التي
تشمل بعض اعضاء حزب العداله والتنميه ومن
جهه اخرى هناك مسؤولون واعضاء لمجلس
الوزراء صرحوا علنا انهم يريدون التمسك
بالبرنامج الحالي لتعزيز الصادرات والنمو
الاقتصاديه
اردوغان بقوائم الاقتراع هذه سنوات من عمر
الانتخابات في البلاد فمنذ عقدين والرئيس
رئيس او مرشح فهذا الرجل الذي اكل الشيب
والسياسه راسه ما زال صوته يسعفه في ان
يخطب بجماهيره الغفيره اذ وظف الموارد
الحكوميه لصالحه وانفق بس خائن على البنيه
التحتيه لارضاء الناخبين
كل هذه الاكياس التي كانت تجهز لتحسي ما
نتائج الانتخابات التركيه تتقدس فيها
اصوات الاتراك والتي اثبتت ان للرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان حصه الاسد فيها
امام منافسه المعارض لا تشدار اوغلو حتى
الان على الرغم من ان هذه الاسواق التركيه
تعج بالمنتجات الا ان الوضع الاقتصادي
المتردي يسمح لعدد كبير من الاتراك
بالمشاهده فقط لا بالشراء اذ يرغب الاتراك
الان بحسب مراقبين ببعض الاستقرار
ويستبعدون فكره التغيير فالبلاد لم تعد
تحتمل اي نوع من المجازفات خاصه وان
الرئيس التركي يلعب على حبال سياسيه عده
قضيه اللاجئين السوريين والتوغل التركي في
شمال الاراضي السوريه فكل هؤلاء المقاتلين
يتدربون منتظرين اشاره واحده من انقره نحو
هدف اضافه الى ان اردوغان قام بسلسله
هجمات عسكريه استهدفت جماعات كرديه في
البلاد وخارج حدود البلاد باتجاه كل من
العراق وسوريا هجمات تباها بانها نفذت عبر
طائرات مسيره وحربيه تركيه الصنع
فالصناعات العسكريه المحليه لقيت صدى
واسعا لدى الناخبين بحسب محللين كانت هذه
السيده تبكي بحرقه قبل اشهر على قبر احد
ضحايا الزلزال لا شك ان وعود اردوغان
باعاده الاعمار لن تبرد من حرقه قلبها
كثيرا فزلزال فبراير جعل بلادا تهتز
باكملها فيما بقي كرسي الحكم ثابتا في
مكانه ينتظر ان كان صاحبه سيعود اليه على
عجل هل العلي العربيه
ومن اسطنبول ينضم الينا المحلل السياسي
التركي مصطفى اوزج ان اهلا بك معنا الليله
سيد مصطفى يعني خلافات داخل حزب العداله
والتنميه اتابع لاردوغان حول السياسه
الاقتصاديه بعد فوزه في حال فاس طبعا كيف
يمكن ان يؤثر ذلك على الانتخابات على
اصوات الناس التي تعاني اصلا من التضخم
العالي من
ليره وانخفاض قيمتها عالميا
نعم هناك تداول اقتصادي لا شك من ذلك هل
هذا يقلل من نجاح فوز رئيس تركي رجب طيب
اردوغان في الجوله الاعاده ربما على اساس
حصل هناك زلزال في جنوب شهر تركيا على
سبيل المثال كهرباء
هذه المدينه ولكن يعني خرجت هناك اصوات
عاليه لتاييد رئيس التركي
وهم يتحسنون بين الايدولوجيه اذا كان يعني
يصوتون او يدلون اصواتهم خلف على خلفيه
ايدولوجيه اذا لم يتغير ولكن نعم هناك
تدهور للاقتصاد وهناك اكثر من
سيناريو فيما بعد الانتخابات ربما يفوز
رئيس في الانتخابات ولكن هذا لا يعني انه
لا يعيد النظر في الاقتصاد في البرنامج
الاقتصادي الحالي الذي يدعمه وزير الماليه
وزير الاقتصاد نرد النباتي ولكن بعض بعض
الاخرين من نفس الحزب هز بالعضله والتنميه
يرون ان هذا البرنامج استنفذ اغراضه لا
يمكن يعني ليس هناك استدامه في
هذه السياسه وهذا البرنامج لانها غير
ناجحه الى حد كبير لابد من تحرير فعيله لا
بد من تحرير طبعا سعر صرف الدولار او
عملات الصعبه كما يرون
اناثت المعارضه الى الحكم او حزب الاضاءه
والتنميه بقي على الحكم لا يتغير ربما ما
الذي بقي بجعبه اردوغان ولم يقدمه اصلا من
سياسات او قرارات اقتصاديه لم يتخذها قبل
يعني لو كان هناك ما ينفع كان اتخذوا قبل
الدخول في هذه الانتخابات واللي هي ستكون
لصالح في حال يعني نسبه التضخم انخفضت
وسعر الليره عاد الى مستواه الطبيعي هل
انت متفائل
بالسياسات الاقتصاديه القادمه مع انه
مؤشري الاسهم التركيه وايضا البنوك
التركيه بعد ظهور النتائج نتائج الجوله
الاولى والتوجه الى جوله ثانيه يعني يوم
الاثنين بعد الاحد انخفضت عندما يعني اسهم
اردوغان ارتفعت بالعوده الى الرئاسه
يعني بعض الخبراء يرون ان لا يستقروا
الامور الاقتصاديا في تركيا قبل حلول
24 يعني بعض السنه والنيف اذا هناك
حاله
تقلبات الاقتصاديه بعد الانتخابات مباشره
ان اتت الى الحكم حزب الاعضاء اين بقيه
اتت
احزاب المعارضه الى الحكم لان هناك بعض
الناس يرون هناك انقاذ اقتصاده
التعويض او تلافي هذا الانقاذ يتطلب وقتا
اذا في ليس اقل من سنه وربما يريد رئيس
تركيا
لا تغيير طقم
[موسيقى]
الماليه على سبيل المثال فهو يتردد اصلا
الى مهما تشمشك لكي يعود الى الحكم او الى
الوزاره وزاره الاقتصاد او الماليه حتى
يستغل الامور حتى الان
لم يعد بشيء يعني عودته الى الى الوزاره
في هذا المجال اذا يعني يبحث رئيس تركي
رجب هاي خيارات جديده وطبعا كل المعارضه
او
غيرهم هم يرون ان الشفاه في العوده الى
الى سياسه التقليديه في الاقتصاد سيد
مصطفى ذكرت نقطه مهمه منذ قليل بانه
المتضررين من الزلزال فضلوا الذهاب
والانتخاب انتخاب اردوغان الذي وعد بخطه
اعاده اعمار يعني
تفضلوا البقاء مع خطط هذه الحكومه هل
سيكررون نفس الخطوه بما يخص الاقتصاد يعني
سيعطون فرصه جديده يعني المزاج التركي على
اي اساس يعمل
يعني كان هناك نقاش في تركيا
الحكم او المؤيدون الحكم يرون ان المعارضه
ستشبث بالبصل يعني
حوالي 30 ليره تركيه هذا مما يعني عضج
ربما طبقه الكياديهين لذلك كان تعويل
عليها الى حد ما ولكن
المؤيدون ان صار هزميه بداوا يستهزون مع
اسعار البصل
واعتماد المعارضه لاسعار البصل وما الى
ذلك اذا نعم الاقتصاد يلعب دورا ولكن كما
ذكرت ان ايدولوجيا ربما يلعب اكثر دورا
لانهم يرون ان ربما مجال المعارضه الى
الحكم ويكون ضياع بالنسبه لتركيا يعني
طبعا هذا ولكن بعض الناس يقتنون على هذه
هذه البرمج او جعيت لذلك يعني نستطيع ان
نقول هناك فرص كثيره بالنسبه لرئيس تركيا
يفوز في الجوله الثانيه ولكن ليس هناك
تاكيد شكرا جزيلا لك المحلل السياسي
التركي مصطفى اوزكان
قائد فاجنر يحذر روسيا ستخسر الحرب ما لم
تتعامل مع النخبه بجديه ومع الاحداث
الدائره تابعونا بعد الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد نواصل من السجال حول سقف
الدين الامريكي وفي اخر التطورات اكد
البيت الابيض ان الملايين قد يفقدون
وظائفهم حاله تخلف عن سداد الدين مشيرا
الى ان ازمه حد الدين العام مصطنعه وحلها
مسؤوليه كل نائب في الكونغرس وعلى الجهه
الاخرى قال رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي
كيفن ماكارتي ان الديمقراطيين يرغبون في
انفاق المزيد مشيرا الى انهم لا يملكون
خطه لذلك دعيا الى حل ازمه الانفعال كما
دعم كارثي الى عدم القاء اللوم على
الجمهوريين بسبب عدم التواصل الاتفاق بشان
سقف الدين
عمار السند
انا لست سيناتورا ولا اسيطر على مجلس
الشيوخ لماذا لم يمرروا قرارا الرئيس لم
يحدثنا لسبعه وتسعين يوما فلا تلقوا
باللوم علي للتواصل مع الديمقراطيين
للتوصل الى الرئيس للقاء والاجتماعي به لا
تلومون على هذا القرار الذي قدمناه نضع
الانفاق للحكومه ونزيده واحد في المئه لكل
عام كي نواكب الاقتصاد كانت هذه فكره
ديمقراطيه فليس ذنب اليوم ان الديمقراطيين
اصبحوا متطرفين جدا وبعيدين جدا باتجاه
الجناح الاشتراكي ويعارضون متطلبات العمل
ويعارضون ادخار الدولار
الولايات الامريكيه عن التخلف عن سداد
ديونها حال عدم الاتفاق على رفع سقف الدين
نتحدث هنا عن الاول من مايو او يونيو
تحديدا لكن ما هي السيناريوهات المطروحه
حتى ذلك اليوم بحسب خبراء الاقتصاد
السيناريو الاول هو التوصل الى اتفاق في
اللحظه الاخيره وهنا حاله عدم اليقين قد
تدفع المستهلكين وايضا المستثمرين
والشركات للتردد في انفاق الاموال ما يزيد
من فرص حدوث ركود وتراجع باسعار الاسهم
السيناريو الثاني هو التوصل الى اتفاق بعد
الموعد النهائي وفي حال تجاوز المفاوضات
الاول من يونيو قد تكون رده الفعل اكثر
حده مثل تراجع الانفاق بشكل كبير وايقاف
الشركات لخطط التوظيف وايضا الاستثمار
ويقدر اقتصاديون ان ينكمش الناتج المحلي
باثنين في المئه في الربع الثالث وخساره
250 الف وظيفه في النصف الثاني من هذا
العام اما السيناريو الثالث فهو عدم
التوصل الاتفاق وفي هذا السيناريو سيتجاوز
الاثر نطاق وحدود الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وستحدث فوضى في النظام
العالمي المالي مع حدوث ركود عالمي اذا
اكثر مما حدث في عام 2008 التباين مازال
سيد الموقف بين الطرفين الاداره الامريكيه
وايضا الكونجرس البيت الابيض يرفضون
اللجوء الى التعديل الرابع عشر من الدستور
لرفع سقف الدين بالقوه ويتهم جمهوري
الكونجرس باخذ الاقتصاد
رهينه اجوندا سياسيه خاصه قبل الانتخابات
الرئاسيه العام المقبل على الضفه الاخرى
يطالب رئيس مجلس النواب كيفن ماكورتي
بموافقه الاداره على اجراء خفض كبير في
نفقات الميزانيه وابقائه عند مستويات عام
2022 معتبرا ان الامر خط احم ر لا يمكن
التنازل عنه الا ان الاداره الامريكيه وما
تواصل المفاوضات قالت ان بعض التقدم حدث
الا انه على الطرفين ان يفهم انهما لن
يحصل على كل ما يرغبان به وفق المتحدثه
باسم البيت الابيض
[موسيقى]
ما هو سقف الدين الامريكي
سقف الدين هو الحد الاقصى للمبلغ الذي
يمكن للحكومه الامريكيه اقتراضه لسداد
التزاماتها الماليه وفق الميزانيه
كمدفوعات تذهب معظم الاموال لدعم برامج
انفاق تشكل ما يقرب من نصف الميزانيه
كالضمان الاجتماعي والرعايه الطبيه ثم
يستحوذ الانفاق العسكري على الجزء الاكبر
الولايات المتحده تنفق اكثر مما تحصل عليه
فتلجا الى الاقتراض وللاستدانه تصدر وزاره
الخزانه اوراق ماليه كسندات الحكوميه
والتي تسدد قيمتها اضافه للفوائد بمجرد
وصول الحكومه الى الحد الاقصى لا تستطيع
وزاره الخزانه اصدار المزيد من السندات
الكونجرس هو الجهه المسؤوله عن رفع سقف
الدين والذي تجاوز الان
31.4 ترليون دولار في حال تخلف الولايات
المتحده عن سداد ديونها لن تكون الحكومه
قادره على دفع رواتب الموظفين الحكوميين
وستتوقف دفعات الضمان الاجتماعي
انضم الينا من واشنطن مراسل العربيه اهلا
بك معنا اذا الاداره الامريكيه تقول بانه
بعض التقدم حدث اين هذا التقدم باي نقاط
تحديدا
ليس واضح لان رئيس مجلس النواب تحدث هذا
الصباح وقال ان الفروقات بين الطرفين ما
زالت كبيره جدا والكلام الايجابي ياتي
عاده في سياق تهدئه الامور وتهدئه الاسواق
المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض تحدثت بلهجه
حاده قبل ساعه من الان عندما افتتحت
الاجاز الصحفي وكما ذكرت قالت ان هذه ازمه
فبركها
الجمهوريون وهي مصطنعه ولا يجب ان نكون
عند هذه النقطه ولا يبدو ان احدا من هذين
الطرفين يريد ان يقول انه يريد ان يقدم
تنازلات في اي نقطه من النقاط التي
يتحدثون عنها ما الذي يملكه باردا
والجمهوريين من نقاط قوه يمكن ان يضغطوا
بها هل هنالك ربما من ماده دستوريه
يستطيعون الذهاب اليها واستعمالها كحل
اخير ربما
للحقيقه للحقيقه هي قضيه سياسيه اكثر مما
هي قضيه دستوريه لان الطرفين يتجهان الى
سيناريو كارثه كما وصفته انت ايضا قبل
قليل اقول انه سياسي لان المبدا الاساسي
في هذه المفاوضات هو الاقتراب قدر الامكان
من نقطه الصفر سوف ينظر الجمهوريون الى
رده فعل الناخب الامريكي سوف ينظر الرئيس
الامريكي الى رد الدفاع الشارع الامريكي
ويجب ان يصلوا الى نوع من تفاهم يريد ان
يقول من خلاله الديمقراطيون انه فعلوا
شيئا من اجل مصلحه الامريكيين ويريد
الجمهوريون ايضا ان يقولوا انهم فعلوا
شيئا من اجل الديمقراطي ولكن ليس بالمعنى
الدستوري او القانوني سوى ان مع اضافه
واحده ان هناك شخص سوف يجلس في وزاره
الخزانه الامريكيه وهو الذي سوف يقرر لول
انهم لم يرفعوا سقف الدين من الذي سوف
تصله الاموال وتدفع له فواتيره ومن هو
الطرف الاخر الذي لم تدفع له فواتك
الشارع الامريكي عن الناس
ومخاوفهم من هذه الازمه
الشارع يريد الشيء وعكسه اولا هم لا
يريدون الدخول في ازمه وبالتالي يريدون من
الطرفين التوصل الى اتفاق ورفع سقف الدين
ولكن هناك نسبه اعلى من ثلث الامريكيين
تقول ان الدين مرتفع ويجب الوصول الى حل
وبالتالي الامريكيون ضائعون بين
الجمهوريين
والديمقراطيين ونحن في فتره حاسمه بالنسبه
للطرفين ومن يكسب الراي العام
اذا شكرا جزيلا لك مراسل العربيه من
واشنطن
لا يكاد يمر خطاب للرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن من دون زلات لسان واخرها فوالي
بايدن اثارات موجه سخريه جديده حيث اختلط
عليه التاريخ والاحداث والشخص
لسان الرئيس الامريكي ينزلق مجددا ويعود
الى نحو 100 عام تقريبا في زله لسان
الاخيره فان نانسي بيلوسي رئيسه مجلس
النواب الامريكي السابقه ساعدت في انقاذ
الاقتصاد في فتره الكساد الكبير اي في عام
في سلسله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
قصبه بسيطه لها فان بيلوسي حينها لم تولد
بعد زله تلقفها مغردون وعلقوا عليها
بطريقتهم فهذا التعليق يذكر ان بيلوسي
ولدت في نهايه الكساد الكبير وهنا اعتبرت
هفوه بايدن افضل مجامله لامراه
سخريه لم تتوقف عند حدود السوشيال ميديا
بل تعدتها الى الفضائيات
الزله الاخيره ليست الوحيده اذ سجلت
لبايدن العديد منها في مره سابقه وربما لم
تكون الاخيره
اعلنا حاكم ولايه فلوريدا راندي سنتيس
تحديه لدون الترامب على ترشيح الحزب
الجمهوري للبيت الابيض في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه لعام 2024 ومن المتوقع ان تكون
فتره الانتخابات التمهيديه للحزب الجمهوري
والتي تدوم 18 شهرا منافسه حاده وصعبه بين
المرشحين الرئيسيين كما كان من المقرر ان
يبدا حاكم ولايه فلوريدا حملته الرئاسيه
رسميا في حدث يبث على تويتر معسكر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اعلنا الجيش الاسرائيلي ان مسيره تابعه
لقواته استهدفت من الاراضي السوريه واردا
على ذلك اطلق الجيش الاسرائيلي النارا نحو
مصدر الهجوم اقل المتحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي في خاي الدرعي المسيره كانت
تقوم بمهمه روتينيه في المنطقه مشيرا الى
ان المسيره انجزت مهامها ولم تسجل اي
اضراره
منع القضاء اللبنانيه حاكم المصرف المركزي
رياض سلامه من السفر بعد استجوابه سلامه
كان مثل اليوم امام المحامي العام
التمييزي في بيروت واستمرت الجلسه ساعه
وعشرين دقيقه
حجز بنتجتها المحامي العام جوازي السفر
حاكم مصرف لبنان لبنان الفرنسي واللبناني
وتركه
رهن التحقيق الى ذلك اجتمع القنصل
الالماني صباح اليوم بالنائب العام
التمييزي القاضي غسان عويدات ووضعه في
صوره مذكره التوقيف الالمانيه الصادره بحق
سلامه في الموازات تقدم وكلاء الحاكم
القانونيون في فرنسا بطعن امام القضاء
الفرنسي لاسترداد مذكره التوقيف الفرنسيه
المعممه عبر النشره الحمراء
[موسيقى]
الاتحاد الافغاني للجامعات ومؤسسات
التعليم العالي الخاصه ان اكثر من 30
جامعه ومؤسسه تعليميه ستتوقف عن انشطتها
التعليميه بسبب مشاكل اقتصاديه
يدرك عبد القدير الراهب دوست رئيس جامعه
اشنا احدى الجامعات الافغانيه الخاصه ان
مستقبل التعليم الخاص في البلاد على المحك
فالتحولات السياسيه وما نجم عنها من سيطره
حركه طالبان على الحكم تركت اثارها على
قطاع التعليم برمته وتحديدا الخاص منه وما
لم يتم استدراكه الوضع الحالي فان نصف
الجامعات الخاصه قد تتوقف عن العمل العام
المقبل
عدد كبير من طلاب جامعه اشنا غادروا
الدراسه للاسف الشديد حيث كان من المتوقع
ان يصبح عدد منهم من الكوادر التعليميه
المتخصصه لكن البعض منهم لزم المنازل فيما
غادر الاخرون البلد الى الخارج
تحذير لا قصداه لدى اتحاد الجامعات
ومؤسسات التعليم العالي الخاصه الاتحاد
اجرى دراسه استقصائيه اوضحت ان معظم
الجامعات الخاصه تعاني ازمات ماليه وهناك
خمس وثلاثون جامعه خاصه لم تعد قادره على
الاستمرار في العمل جراء هذه الازمات
فنضغته
مع الاسف الشديد ومنذ اسابيع تم تسريح سته
الاف موظف من هذه الجامعات وقد تسبب هذا
القرار في اغلاق الجامعات امام الفتيات
وانخفاض في وتيره الالتحاق بها وفقا
لمعلومات اتحاد الجامعات الخاصه فان هناك
140 جامعه خاصه ومؤسسه للتعليم العالي في
البلاد ونحو 130 الف طالبا وسبعين الف
طالبه كانوا يدرسون في هذه الجامعات
الخاصه بالاضافه الى توفر فرص عمل لحوالي
25 الف شخص
اذا لم تتعلم الفتيات والسيدات فان
مستقبلهن لن يكون افضل ولن يعيش المجتمع
حياه مناسبه وستنحصر عمليه العلم والتعليم
على الذكور فقط
نطالب النظام الحاكم بايجاد فرص للتعليم
ومن ثم فرص العمل وايجاد بيئه مناسبه
للشباب حتى يستطيعوا بناء مستقبل افضل لهم
زملائي لا يستطيعون دفع الرسوم الدراسيه
وذلك لضعف اقتصاد اسرهم اما بالنسبه لي
فانا لي اخا يعمل في الخارج وهو يقوم
بمساعده في سداد الرسوم الدراسيه
يرى مسؤول الجامعات الخاصه ان غياب المراه
الافغانيه عن الجامعات يتسبب في افلاس هذه
الجامعات ولتغلب على هذا الظرف الصعب فقد
اعفت السلطات في كابول الجامعات والمدارس
الخاصه لعام كامل من ضريبه الارباح بنسبه
اربعه نادر العربيه كابول
[موسيقى]
بعد ان اجتاحت سوره انفجار مقر وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
ونفاها البنتاجون سريعا تراجعت البورصه
لفتره قصيره لكنها كانت كفيله بجعل
المستخدمين لا يثقون باخبار تويتر ويوجهون
اتهامات للملياردير الامريكي بجعله ارضا
خصبه للاخبار الزائفه طبعا جعل تويتر ارضا
خصبه للاخبار الزائفه
انفجار في البنتاجون
[موسيقى]
دمار نفته الدفاع الامريكيه لكن رماده
وبحسب الخبراء جعل من تويتر منصه لم تعد
قابله للتصديق
طلب صام التمان احد ابرز مطوري انظمه
الذكاء الاصطناعي وعدد اخر من الخبراء
بتشكيل وكاله عالميه لمراقبه هذا النشاط
على شاكله الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه النوويه
معتبرين ان خطر الذكاء الاصطناعي بات يهدد
الوجود البشري بشكل حقيقي حيث ان بعض
انظمه الذكاء الاصطناعي يمكن ان تكون اكثر
ذكاء من مطورها
تذكرون فيلم ماتريكس وماذا حل بالبشر
عندما اصبحت الالات اكثر ذكاء
الامر لم يعد خيالا علميا فابرز مطوري
انظمه الذكاء الاصطناعي
يطالب بتشكيل وكاله دوليه لحمايه البشر من
هذا الذكاء بعد ان اصبح اكثر ذكاء من
صانعي
[موسيقى]
بينما نتجه نحو الذكاء الاصطناعي العام
والتاثير الذي سيكون له وقوه تلك
التكنولوجيا اعتقد اننا بحاجه الى التعامل
مع ذلك بجديه مثل ما نتعامل مع تقنيات
اخرى قويه جدا وهذا هو المكان الذي اعتقد
فيه شخصيا اننا بحاجه الى مخطط شامل
بينما كان التمن يقدم افادته للكونجرس
الامريكي حول الذكاء الاصطناعي وجدت هذه
الشابه ضالتها العاطفيه نديما يشاركها
الاحساس والمشاعر وقد يلتقيان ويتبادلان
التجارب وفي الحقيقه انه وهم انه الذكاء
الاصطناعي الذي وصل حد التلاعب بمشاعر
البشر
كانت هذه القنبله اهم تحد لوجود البشر
لذلك اقيمت وكاله دوليه لمراقبه الانشطه
النوويه اليوم مبتكر الذكاء الاصطناعي
يحذرون من ان الخطر على الوجود قد يكون
كاملا في جهاز حاسوب او هاتف النقال لذلك
اصبحت الحاجه ماسه لتشكيل وكاله دوليه
لمراقبه الذكاء الاصطناعي وابتكاراته
خيرها وشرها
[موسيقى]
الى تصريح اليوم روسيا قد تواجه ثوره
مماثله لثوره العام 1917 وتخسر الحرب في
اوكرانيا ما لم تتعامل النخبه بجديه مع
الاحداث الدائره هذه كانت كلمات قائد
مجموعه فاجنر العسكريه الخاصه
الذي حذر من ان اوكرانيا تعد لهجوم مضاد
يهدف الى دحر القوات الروسيه الى حدود ما
قبل عام 2014 اي عندما ضمت روسيا شبه
جزيره القرن
صوره اليوم من كوريا الشماليه اذ ظهر
الزعيم كيم جونغ ان منحنيا في مشهد لم
تشهده البلاد سابقا الصوره نشرت في صحيفه
محليه او اظهرت الزعيم الكوريه الشمالي
راكعا امام قبر مسؤول عسكري وهو امر غير
مسبوق القبر يعود لهيون تشول هاي الذي
توفي العام الماضي وبحسب مصادر محليه فقد
كرسهاي حياته للعمل حارسا لعائلتك وقد
احيت البلاد ذكره قبل ايام
طفوله لم يعيشها كما يجب حرمه فقدان البصر
في سن الثانيه عشره من حياه طبيعيه
كاقرانه لهذا السبب قرر تكريس جهوده
للاطفال المكفوفين وسيم الاسم والطباع
يعمل معلما لمساعده الذين يعانون من اعاقه
بصريه على تعلم المهارات لممارسه حياتهم
اليوميه اسس في دمشق معهدا لتعليم الاطفال
كيفيه الكتابه والقراءه باستخدام طريقه
برايل كما يقدم وسيم انشطه ترفيهيه له
[موسيقى]
اشكركم مشاهدينا على حسن المتابعه وننتقل
الى الزميل صهيب شراير واخبار الساعه مساء
الخير صهيب راويه مساء الخير بعد قليل
جولتنا الاخباريه السريعه الشامله
والمتنوعه اخبار الساعه في الصداره
المواجهه الروسيه الاوكرانيه الوضع في
السودان واعلان دسانتس ترشحه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات